good afternoon it's noon here in New
York State on Long Island in the United
States and I want to welcome all of you
wherever you are right now to this
presentation vaginitis vaginosis
diagnosis and work up using conventional
and molecular methods I'm Cynthia
Baumann on the medical director Enzo
clinical labs in Long Island and I'm
very pleased to be joined by my
colleague dr. Hank Wang today who is the
chief of the microbiology labs at
Westchester Medical Center and also our
microbiology consultant at ENSO clinical
labs just to give you a little bit of
housekeeping we will divide the seminar
into two portions today I will discuss
the conventional workup and dr. Wang
will discuss the molecular workup we'll
each talk for approximately 20 to 25
minutes we're hoping that we have a at
least 10 minutes of conversation and
we're really hoping for some active
discussion and for people to offer their
own experiences in order for me to talk
about conventional methods I will also
need to introduce some clinical concepts
to frame issues we're discussing this
issue today because it's an extremely
important one it affects most women over
the course of their lifetime and it it
consumes a number of health care
resources at least a billion dollars a
year in the US it's also characterized
by asymptomatic States many health
related consequences it's not a simple
disorder or condition it has complicated
and persistent or recurrent estates and
with the evolving technology that we
have now we now have a new or enhanced
understanding of the conditions and
we're be examining some of those are the
most common causes are bacterial
vaginosis Volvo vaginal vaginal
candidiasis and trichomoniasis from
trichomonas vaginalis the images here
just are quickly to orient you on the
upper right hand frame you'll notice the
typical clue cells on a wet
prep of BB below on the left bottom
you'll see the typical high fee and bugs
of Canada and then on the bottom right
you'll see the typical flat flagella of
a trip amonos on a wet prep you'll
notice that some of these are not easy
to see and that's one of the things
we'll discuss now one of the topics
we're not going to discuss today's
treatment which could take a whole hour
in and of itself there are also many
other organisms that can coexist or can
present symptoms that may overlap with
the disorders we'll talk about today
there are a number of conditions which
can coexist with or can cause similar
conditions we won't discuss them but we
need to be aware of the fact that the
normal physiologic variation and a
woman's vaginal secretions atrophic
vaginitis lichen sclerosus foreign
bodies notably retain tampons and
contact dermatitis among other things
can mimic some of these conditions the
definition of vaginitis is fairly
straightforward its vaginal disorders
which are usually caused by infection
associated with inflammation and a
discharge and they may have odor itching
or discomfort but vaginosis is a little
more difficult to define there is no
inflammation so we call it vaginosis and
not itís but it's not a single entity a
diagnosis that we could use is that it's
a polymicrobial condition with very
variable composition of vaginal
organisms variable symptoms and
expression and response to treatment and
it's characterized by a change in the
quantity and quality of the normal left
of a silly in the vagina with a
multifold increase in other organisms
including anaerobes it's basically a
change in the ecosystem of their vagina
now there are many organisms that can be
associated with vivi and the normal and
the vaginal flora and gardnerella
vaginalis out of cobia mobile Uncas
megasphere ax + B the associated
bacteria some very common ones but there
are a number of others and I have not
listed all of those here in order to
frame this discussion we need to have
some discussion about the
vaginal microbiota me or the microbiota
or for some of us have been around a
while the normal flora of the vagina and
we need to realize that our
understanding has changed and that
so-called normal flora is very dynamic
it may change over time be related to
different parts of the genital tract
some of someone's lifestyle the genotype
of the patient or the organism ethnicity
immune status and environment and
usually we think of the vaginal
ecosystem as being dominated by wanted
to lactobacilli but that's not always
the cases we're finding usually these
organisms produce lactic acid which
keeps the vagina at a PA at an acid pH
between 3.8 and 4.2 and they may produce
hydrogen peroxide and together both of
these create an inhospitable environment
for other organisms however we have a
question about what is really normal
right now and I'm sure dr. Wang will
discuss that and it may not just simply
be a matter of good lactobacilli and bad
gardnerella we have other concepts we
have to consider whether you've got
something as a commensal or it's
pathologic whether something is just
colonising or overgrown in the vagina so
we realized that the definition or the
concept of the vaginal microbiome E is
evolving and we have issues of how we
define that as with culture and
molecular techniques one of the problems
that both of these techniques present us
is that we have a hard time identifying
or giving priority to low-frequency
organisms now another reason we're
having this conversation or this session
today is again there are many adverse
clinical consequences associated with
these disorders and I've already
mentioned that they can have complicated
or uncomplicated infections they can
recur or persist but they also have
profound effects on pregnancy and a
fetus they predispose someone for STDs
and they're more common with STDs when
you have them you may acquire HIV more
easily and have a higher viral load and
you also have the increased risk of
server
epithelial neoplasia with persistence of
hpv16 now to first discuss bacterial
vaginosis V vaginosis again it's the
most common of the three conditions it
can be higher in specific groups but
like other condition of these conditions
many if not most of them can be
asymptomatic and one woman's bv may not
be another woman's bv they're very
variable clinical patterns weekend with
unique and dynamic phases even within
the same patient risk factors include
being african-american and although
they're not supposed to be STDs they are
more common when someone has had more
recent or sexual partners they're also
more common in women who have sex with
women and women who have sex without
barrier production protection or who
used dushore intravaginal substances and
and disrupt their therefore their
vaginal environment one of the problems
with BB is a high incidence of
recurrence and at one year this may be
up to fifty percent and and we're not
sure whether this is because of a
persistence of the organisms a failure
to recolonize with the normal
lactobacilli or whether women keep
getting reinfected the classical
diagnosis has been a clinical one based
on the amsel criteria and these involves
three or four typical presentations on
the loader is fishy homogeneous milky
white adherent discharge a vaginal pH of
greater than 4.5 so getting becoming
more alkaline many clue cells on a wet
prep and clue cells represent apathy
lleol cells to which anaerobes
especially gardnerella have adhered and
then a positive amine or with test with
ten percent Koh and we'll discuss these
the problem with is this clinical
diagnostic scheme is the standardization
of it and the resources you need which
includes microscopy now the microscopic
diagnosis of BD is considered to be the
research or the gold standard diagnosis
but it's not really practical at the
point of
here and generally what it involves is
making a sphere and sending that to a
microbiology lab and having either a
technologist or a microbiologist read it
and someone with expertise it obviously
takes skills and it can be very
objective but again not practical there
are several different schemes the most
important or common of which is the
Nugent score and I've just shown that
here I won't go into great detail but
basically of the reader divides the
bacteria into three groups of
morphotypes lactobacilli gardnerella and
bacteroides and then a curve curved gram
variable rod population generally
mobileuncle species and these are graded
and scored and at the bottom of the
slide you can see if you have a score of
0 to 3 you're considered to be normal
for 26 your intermediate flora and have
to use other criteria and seven to 10 is
supposed to be diagnostic of BB now
these slides here show typical patterns
the first two frames have ample but
lactobacilli and are considered normal
the second two frames are an
intermediate category where you see
fewer decreasing like the bacilli and
emerging gram positive or gram variable
rods or curve drugs and/or kaka bacilli
and then the bottom two are obviously an
overgrowth of a floor without
lactobacilli of their consistent art
with being diagnostic of BB there's
another classification that I will not
discuss but it's called the ice on hayde
classification and it simplifies things
by having only two morphotypes
lactobacilli and gardnerella but it also
has a grading and scoring system now
culture has been used for baby but it's
not used very regularly and it has
limitations because what we're talking
about is fastidious organisms or
anaerobes and choosing the right media
and identification schemes can be a
challenge the other problem you get into
is the same problem you get into with
molecular techniques and that's
identifying the profile of the pattern
identifying the priority or the
importance of the
juicy and whether they're overgrown or
whether you're not picking them up the
ph is one near and dear to my heart
because I've had a lot of experience
with this over the course of my career
it's not always as easy there is a CLIA
waived a card that you can use for pH
but most people discuss the pH in terms
of pH paper and if any of you have had
lab experience you know even from your
college or graduate school days that Q
seeing that pH paper or making sure it's
stable can be difficult your some people
say you're not supposed to put it
directly on vaginal mucosa but I know
practitioners who do the scale that you
have for reading can determine how you
read it you're supposed to read a pH
within several minutes at room
temperature and a big problem with pH is
that it's affected by a number of
substances that are normally found or
air usually found in the vagina
including blood semen an atrophic
environment and intravaginal substances
such as douches or creams and
trichomonas vaginalis as well as
inflammatory conditions I live in New
York and so we there's no as such thing
as a wave test in a licensed environment
and so we have to you know be able to QC
these have training of competency have
lot numbers and everything consequently
it makes it difficult to use pH paper
the width test is a result of the
bacterial the anaerobic bacteria of
producing enzymes that break down the
peptides of the normal vaginal
epithelial cells and this these create
volatile and malodorous means and
generally this is enhanced by using Koh
there are a couple of CLIA waived or
rapid tests here that just can check for
the the amines or the enzymes but most
people described using Koh and i also
have a spotted history with koh i recall
it as dripping models of caustic
substances creating messy workstations
and doing nasty things to microscopes
however today you can buy these in
ampules and it's easier to use advanced
diagnosis dr. Wang will discuss and this
advanced diagnosis including probes and
molecular techniques has pointed out
some of the shortcomings of our
conventional methods I'll move on to a
Volvo vaginal candidiasis or BBC and
this affects most women at least once or
more in their life as we all know Canada
is part of the normal skin and vaginal
flora at least ten twenty percent of
women are colonized with it you can
normally have Candida but becomes
pathologic when it invades your
epithelial cells and the question is why
does that happen on that typical
organisms involved are albicans which
accounts for the vast majority of these
cases glabrata however can happen is
present and is more common in diabetic
women and in postmenopausal women and
there's an increase in glabrata
parapsilosis and tropicalis with age
plus glabrata crusie I and tropicalis
may be drug resistance the picture I
have here is from a pap smear and it's
pretty obvious that there's heavy
candida overgrowth and it's involving
cells in a pathologic way risk factors
for a Volvo vaginal candidiasis may
involve perturbations in the immune
system on diabetes out of control
antibiotic therapy or HIV infection
there's also a genetic component where
there may be abnormal binding to the
epithelial cells and in Flint and hosted
climate or response Canada is felt to
migrate from the GI tract and the anus
into the vaginal tract while it's not
supposed to be an STD it is more common
in women who have had commenced sexual
exposure and it's also more common in
women who engage in oral genital and
anal genital sex both areas of which are
rich sources of Canada one of the
problems with Canada is that women
self treat or self-diagnosis
self-diagnosed right now and they may be
selecting out for resistant organisms
the typical clinical appearance of vbc
is a thick cheesy cottage cheese like
discharged attached to the side wall
without odor and Canada presents with
prominent / itís and soreness and
irritation and it's not uncommon to see
fishers and excoriation in the vagina
and vulva the diagnosis again is
typically described as being made on a
wet mount with either saline or ten
percent Koh the sensitivity may be only
fifty percent even the makers of the
ampules of Koh will say that you should
be very careful when you're using it
because it can be very hard to
distinguish you have to be expert or
experienced in distinguishing fungal
elements you can see I'm not crazy about
Koh the pH should be normal or acidic
the cultures can be used especially if
you have resistant organisms or
recurrent organisms and you want to
speciated get sensitivities we
frequently see if the pap smear or we
Canada on pap smears but the
significance of that is uncertain and
I've just for completeness I've listed
the probe and the PCR methods but dr.
Wang will discuss those Canada can have
a complicated presentation with very
severe signs and symptoms and it in five
to eight percent of women it can have a
recurrent pattern or RV DC and those are
usually non albicans or glabrata species
and they can happen for more times a
year and that may be one of the reasons
that you would do cultures and
sensitivities now finally I'll move to
trip amonos vaginalis infection and this
is the most frequent non-viral STD it's
a human parasite only have collided
tropa so a protozoan in the US the
Rangers were wide but I think it's
probably at least seven million cases a
year in the worldwide it's felt that
there are at least 180 million cases a
year
the prevalence widely varies and between
low and high risk groups to between
around one percent to about sixty
percent it is once again more common in
african-americans and it may be up to
fifty percent of women who present for
vaginal symptoms may have trichomonas we
definitely are seeing we have a changing
understanding of the prevalence of it
with our application methods the picture
I have here is a pap smear and these I
don't have a pointer right now but these
small amorphous bodies on the top of the
picture are tricky monads and one of the
problems that a when you have with pap
smears is that you can either under over
call trichomonas on them the risk
factors are those of a typical STD it's
the number of sexual partners one has
socioeconomic status whether one it uses
barrier protection with sex and the
history of other STDs on there is a
problem with recurrence with a
trichomonas and that can either
represent continued sexual activity
during treatment having a new partner or
not effectively treating a one's current
partner and not using barrier protection
with sexual activity compliance with
treatment and then one can also get
resistant trichomonas the clinical
presentation of trichomonas vaginalis is
described as a frothy grey green vaginal
discharge it may be foul it can also
present with itching and petechial but
the strawberry cervix pattern is built
to be rare or not this common as stated
it can have all of our changes like
Canada interestingly with the
trichomonas it can involve glands Perea
retool glands the cervix and the bladder
so it can be a more complicated
infection and in men it can present with
urethritis prostatitis and epididymitis
now the diagnosis of tripped amonos is
similar to the other conditions you can
do wet mounts you need to carefully
preserve those and
those within 10 to 20 minutes some
people say up to an hour i think the
shorter time is probably better to make
sure you actually are seeing the
motility of the flagella but again those
that sensitivity may only be fifty to
seventy percent the ph should be like BB
it should be greater than 4.5 you may
elect or there are cultural
opportunities to use especially if you
suspect trichomonas and you have a lot
of Polly's in a discharge but you
haven't seen it on a wet prep there is a
rapid antigen a swab test which is
supposed to be eighty eight percent
positive I'm not sure how frequently
that is used and then I've listed again
for completeness the probe and the PCR
method and there are some common themes
I hope they've covered here are
presented the first one is that the
clinical diagnosis which can be the
bedrock for these conditions may not
always be so straightforward or so
standard and it may not be accurate
simple quick methods that we've all
grown up with may not be so simple it
may not be so quick and they do require
a certain amount of skill to do and
experience you need resources with these
you need to be able to either do the pH
or do the wet preps and have microscopy
and you need to maintain that and be
able to read those preparations and
therefore the adoption of some of those
these techniques and clinical settings
may not be as common and finally one
thing that I found throughout my career
with these entities is it's been very
very difficult to work out correlations
with clinics who are making clinical
diagnosis and the laboratory that's
making a laboratory diagnosis are and
and being equivalent you're getting some
agreement has been very frustrated
frustrating um there are certainly new
definitions with molecular methods and I
am very very pleased to turn this over
right now to my colleague dr. Wang who
will continue with that conversation
hello everyone there that I'm back along
that the moment just before excellent
the reviewing the epidemiology clinical
presentations diagnosis and woke up by
conventional method what I'm going to do
to provide you some update in the
diagnosis and work up by molecule
message so first I will briefly review
that test the method and be our
availabilities and then our focus on the
performance of different molecular tests
for diagnosis of trichomonas for
professional candidiasis and bacterial
vaginosis as well as they are clinical
indication will go I may mention some
commercial tests I have nothing to
disclose three type photographer
molecule method for diagnosis of African
artists pitino sixx our country are
available that direct the probe
hybridization big [ __ ] acid
amplification test and the DNA sequence
basis method we will not have time to
cover the details for each muscle what I
want you point out is the major
difference between the firsta tube
method since the probe hybridization
method detect the target by director
hybridization between complementary
nucleic acid without amplification of
the target in the clinical sample there
are sensitivity it's hugely lower when
compared to nucleic acid amplification
test assaulted
there are 22 FDA Korean War nuclear
tests for diagnosis of Aphrodite's
vaginosis they're from the firm 53 from
the bath tongue Dixon and their optimal
trichomonas fraternities essays from the
King probe now part of the Hologic
meanwhile a number of our laboratory
development test either use commercially
available like a research use only
regent or home protest that have been
widely used in some clinical laboratory
for diagnosis of African Isaac
technologies and Freddie gnosis so the
PD affirmed 53 microbial identification
test is the first molecule test approved
by FDA for diagnosis of our foreign
ideas ready gnosis in 1993 is a director
are they probe hybridization test for
the detection of the three major causes
of our fragile Isis the candida species
garden rather fraternities and
trichomonas vaginalis in vaginal fluids
basement from patient with some simple
terms of vaginitis and Freddie gnosis so
the the analytical sensitive sensitivity
of the answer excuse me the underneath
your sensitivity of the PDA phone
previously test is about like ten
thousand save you for candida species
200,000 save you for garden arena of
virgin Ares and the 5,000 for
trichomonas vaginalis there
diagnostic sensitivity and of the
affirmed Isis face from a 70 to 90 s
with a high specificity for candida
species and trichomonas and the relative
lower specificity about eighty-two
percent for diagnosis orpha in bacterial
vaginosis according to the package
insert from the manufactures the optima
trichomonas vaginalis sa is fda
chameleon for detection for trichomonas
vaginalis in fresno endocervical swap
female urine Allison traps placements in
the tightness system in 2011 and more
recently on the price alert system it is
a tma test targeting a specific region
of the 60s ribosome our aid for the
apexi is set actually it's there shall
be the 80s ribosome ra the analytical
sensitivity of the optima click molars
SI or the 0.1 take one of cell / deals
of sample the clinical sensitivity of
the optimal trichomonas se its high is
very from ninety five percent for urine
sample and up to a hundred percent for
vaginal and the cervical and the purpose
near samples to raise the studies they
compare the performance of the PDF from
53 and with the optimal trick melissa s
is the first to study including what is
several hundred contact the patient we
saw 13 ids from the Northeast US while
the second study included 322 some
traumatic illness from associate the US
work then the preference is very
different we see the problem turbulence
in the first study is 520 and insert
almost seventeen percent both studies
have demonstrated that the Optima the
tmas is is much more sensitive than the
firm 53 test with no surprise as a way
mention some additional study have also
compared the performance of the optimal
tmas is with a direct test method
including microscopy exam you of what
amount preparation culture and the PCR
so it appears that all study always have
the same conclusions that the tma and
the PCR are the most sensitive and the
specific method for detecting for
trichomonas different and Ledisi
infections so some of us may ask a
question is also the content
recommendations on the use of our
molecule test for diagnosis and the
screening of our trichomonas vaginalis
infection so first I think molecule
testing is pregnant it's clearly
indicated for clinical diagnosis of our
trichomonas an infection in
sympathomimetic patient without
retinitis second molecule testing can be
useful at the nautical service as you
would provide more accurate of
preference data with the study
population third shall we screaming a
simple medical patient without retinal
complaints the probe for screening in
clear that are higher prevalence as
suggested by latest the molecular
testing it depending with the patient
population is could be five to twelve
thirteen percent also as many as fifty
patient with a three-component infection
could it be a simple method obviously
this number may fairly depend in the
study patient population cause they're
trichomonas infection could have a
number for health accountant points and
the
the disease is critical the cause is
whether this gradient approach is
cost-effective and the were so the
cranial vault trichomonas may have very
limited the impact on public health
currently the CDC recommends that the MU
screen and am basically she'll be
performing HIV positive a female and the
screening test can be conceived for some
finger in high risk such as those with a
new or multiple partners commercial sex
workers in your vendors drug users and
the individuals with a preference
history of sexually transmitted
infection so let's move to the focal
bachelor candidiasis multicab tests that
are available for diagnosis of for
fertility devices including the fda
clear the BB affirmed 53 microb
identification test and the number of
our laboratory develop nucleic acid
amplification test the n/a a t-test they
are attractive since they are since they
are multiple copies per tsunami for some
target such as the ribosome PA it could
pretend with somewhat a hundred copies
per genome e of the organizer also the
nucleic acid base si if they can be
mated left for detection for different
the candida species and for simultaneous
detection for candida and other original
questions that are two by use the same
samples at sunrise in the tables there
are from 53 you do have our sensitivity
or 462 eight-person pcr nearly appear to
be more sensitive than the PD affirmed
53 essays and also more sensitive than
culture
the question again is when a molecule
test shall be useful diagnosis of full
professional candidiasis in a simple
magic or simple method patient because
our high percentage of a healthy woman
could colonize with a candida species so
that Monica testing for candida species
in general is not recommended for
individual without freaking itís for
patient with virginal complains or
suspected offer for professional
candidiasis medical tests can be an
option but culture and I'll still in the
recommended test observe the four
patient ways are complicated like a
photo vaginal candidiasis the patient
was a recurrent fantasy or patient may
have been infected with some more
candida albicans were in other case
could be knighting in pregnant woman's
we had even for the diagnosis clearly
monica test can be also used for
epidemiological surveys and for
predicting hunter funko susceptibilities
especially in the case of a candida
glabrata or canada cruiser infection
diagnosis and the workup of a pet or for
bacterial vaginosis by conventional
faceless molecule test as doctrine
bomber mentioned the team major approach
in confessional pv woke up our clinical
and the Gram stain basis m search
criteria and the Gram stain basis nugent
school the challenges with the post
mesle are the subjective interpretation
and poor clinical correlation also the
majority of a pv associated bacteria
they are fast titties on the ropes
either they are fairly
to the culture or the some of them are
unconscionable therefore molecule
approach 70 with over alternative for
diagnosis of the bacterial vaginosis to
develop are appropriate molecular se for
diagnosis of a bacterial vaginosis first
we need to know which bacteria are the
most likely associated with sub bday I
believe we are made a big progress in
this field in the past few years and as
a first idly by use either culture
dependent or coach and culture
independent method such as a targeted
quantitative PCR six years representing
a basic metagenomic and whole genomic
sequence analysis we identified a number
of people associated bacteria this
family have now been used for
development of a new molecular
diagnostic test second the latest the
molecule studies led us to some new
concept or vaginal microbiota or
bacterial micro communities nowaday were
more focus on the virginal microbiota
and their impact on health and disease
instead of making for individual
microorganism the third we also
identified now we know there are
different species don't run
lactobacillus species yes and they are
they may have different the
physiological and the person logical
functions in health and the development
no for bacterial vaginitis so the table
this slides just summarize you some
those most calm buffet associated
bacteria determined by turkey the
quantitative PCR we can see the presence
of carbon runner for the Nellie's is a
highly sensitive but less specific while
some other newly identified
the pv associated bacteria to be baby
they are both sensitive and specific for
diagnosis of for pv so this search
here's the Runkle abundance on the
percentage of clothes in the library
crispin into specific bacteria 60s
ribosome the a sequence he has subjected
before assuming the pen name in the left
side and after she in penalty on the
right side the whole set of apathy we
can say on the note the pool in love the
panel will be saved before the new set
of a PV the fentanyl microbiota in
predominant by left of bacillus and one
winger after a set of the DV so that the
microbiota clearly like a chance soup
switched to a much more that first like
a microbiota which is predominant by
gardnerella vaginalis and a number of
other an aerobic gram-negative bacteria
so this looks like a bit more
complicated so basically is summarized
data or full be free associated bacteria
from three recent like a whole genome
sequence basis microb study the study
number one is a label like a one two
three studied number one that's in
create 132 hiv-positive African woman
from Tanzania sorry number two included
100 Chinese woman and study number three
including about almost 400 us woman if
we located the left panels what we found
is that regardless of the patient
population there are micro bio me in
individual with a no Nugent score that's
a million scored zero to six are
dominant by negative bocinas
what do we do say we also say some
different like up between like a
different patient populations you may
locate the right panels in patient was a
high nuke in the school I much that
first microbiota are demonstrated which
included their present of some PV
associated microorganism as we
highlighted in red in the slides so
except for the PDF from 53 right now
there is no fda-approved or canoeing
nucleic acid amplification essays for
diagnosis of the three original OSIS
here are summarized data from two recent
public publishes studies in the first
one for real-time quantitative pcr for
detection of eight EV associated
bacteria or use it to you analyzed 231
French the sample with a Nugent school
in the circumstance to real-time semi
quantitative pcr for detective over for
pv associated bacteria will use that you
analyze 169 prospective at 227 which was
back in fresno samples based on the
opposite of the quantity or some pv
associated a microorganism or by using
our combined PSR score closest study
demonstrated that multiple as pcr se are
highly sensitive and specific for Tagle
osis of bacterial vaginosis so certainly
I think both study i think is still we
are with you still need the make up more
study to are verified our 30-day to disa
finest but it is certainly the return
multiplex pcr looks very promising so
several like the next regeneration
sequence platform that including the
and it's the sample of them such as the
alumina my seat hi sick the a/b sony ion
torrent and rose 454 so i think the
major advantage 44 NGS basis study is
that they are capacity for simultaneous
detection identification and
quantification offer multiple his
uncle's could be all cognate we
interests including some antimicrobial
resist the new markers so as a show you
only this guy's original studies I see
with some 163 Sweden women's I've found
that the measurement of owner abundance
of normal and BFA associated in
microbiota relativity the total
bacterial was the most accurate method
for PV diagnosis in this studies what
are they found that the depletion of the
natural personas let's say if he is a
relative quantity or the less than forty
seven percent trust their present of
either gardnerella vaginalis or Auto
problem have our sensitivity or four
ninety seven percent and a specificity
or 496 present so we started wrongs in
Monica diagnostic technologies we expect
the next generation of tools for
diagnosis of vaginitis Fred gnosis would
certainly include the improves the
multiplex nucleic acid amplification
test some whole genome sequence basis
test and some mota verdiant algorithm
basic test perhaps fear of us or the
argue that they're advancing molecule
Douglas of 13 itís very noses will
benefit the patient by providing more
sensitive and accurate that losses for
patient management
on the other hand the use of our medical
tests 70 well increase the cost of are
already over kind of overburden you as a
health care system as Kenisha have a
question about the one thousand dollar
per venire so when they face the same
equation weather is worse to use
molecular testing for diagnosis of 30
90s Freddie gnosis either as an
individual test or as a panel I don't
think where you have a definitive or
consensus answer to this question is
maybe yes maybe no so certainly will be
depending on the time place or the
patient the medical condition as well I
think that's what we are I have so thank
you for your attending so I think we
sure have for some time for the
discussions or Christian so thank you
we'll see whether we can get in I don't
know whether Hank and I can get in and
the frame together here but certainly
that was a masterful excellent
presentation and I hope that we framed
this difficult a new area for you what
we would really like is to have some
discussion to hear some of your
experience or some of your questions
clearly this is a very promising area
where we can be much more accurate and
definitive in our diagnosis but the
question is at what cost or what is a
effective use of this technology I don't
see that we have any questions right now
and you know certainly we encourage you
if you have any thoughts about this
while we're waiting for questions and
hope we get them Hank and I took a look
at the cost of these tests and it's very
hard to take a look at across because we
have different regional carriers and
there are different insurance shores and
these patients are frequently non
Medicare patients not always but
frequently
but we did some cost analysis and I
think we came through with some similar
conclusions that certainly be easier the
conventional tests are reimbursed down
in the three to ten or fifteen dollar
range so I don't want to be more
specific than that one of the questions
the problems that the probe tests are
reimbursed I think we're talking Hank
are we talking in the $42 range of there
and and again it depends upon the
numbers of probes or the whether you
build by probe or whether it's a
complete affirm on the molecular tests
we're seeing them on being billed at the
step at several hundred dollar range and
the question is is what the insurers are
paying and you know what patients are
bearing or what a reference lab is
bearing on these and then one has to ask
for the clinical benefit and I see we
have a question right now is what the
sensitivity specificity positive
predictive value negative predictive
value of the FDA cleared assays compared
to the nugent score thank you ok this
way I think I want to clarify I think
that you talked about the new to the
school that you must be an affair to
some diagnostic test for the bacterial
vaginosis but then right now the only
one that could be used for that is the
PD our firm like 53 microb
identification system I think for their
I think of what what they they compare
attendees the is the culture yea big
yeah it'll my kids in the common is the
culture test windia with the FDA
submission dieter Peggy appeared in the
back near set and
the general the general conclusion is
that the conventional tests are maybe
cheaper but there are among the less
sensitive tests the affirmed you know
that they're less sensitive than culture
which is maybe less sensitive than the
affirmed which is clearly less sensitive
than the molecular methods is that right
at Rio so Park as we mentioned that test
the meso section so clearly the BB
affirmed so it's a directive probe
amplification without amplification of
the target so that's what we are is no
surprises says did need usually is
Norton amplification like a basis test
so I gave for for for the for the first
question I think we're only one of the
approved test for their for the
diagnosis all for the two opportunities
and that is mainly based on the
detection of our cantarella 3930 Lenny's
and the other one the a positive result
is dad's suggestive for DV but clearly
is not that lipstick for bday so that's
what we say it happen if you just use a
user control opportunities there's a
indicators for PV so is do you have a
higher sensitivity but the low specific
cities we do have a couple of other
questions we see and we want to thank
one of the attendees thanked us for the
presentation and we appreciate that you
know with Roger attended we'd love to
hear other people's experience another
question is do you have to validate the
molecular testing to the conventional
test and yes you do the the pcrs and the
multiplex and I Hank and I have been
involved in doing that we're currently
very actively involved in that in our
laboratory hang up well let you discuss
some of the basic issues yeah I think I
certainly according to you it's a museum
day in the US I think a 44
a home-and-home purring like a body good
test the laboratory have to establish
the performance of a test as in the
quizzes how to validate how to establish
the performance typically that will be
included analytical sensitivity super
silly cities the accuracy if you the
quantity test will be the limit or for
detections and another interference so
for those I think there will be
certainly we have we have those who have
the penetrated but they exactly like a
phony individual tests so we were funny
bear any test we may have to select like
a comparators so I think in that case
will be the generally idea will be if
there are any FDA approved test for that
particular like target let's say if you
want to validate and laboratory develop
not test for detection for trichomonas
vaginalis because right now there are
two FBA appropriate test so you may want
if you select to compare your Monica
test to that to another FDA approved the
Monica test so 70 in some case if there
are no fda-approved test and then you
may vary daily your Monica test against
some conventional test so that's really
what we depend exactly the target the
Monica tells you are going to you funny
they did if and I think another comment
to make again we live in New York and so
we abide by all New York regulations and
that's a good thing in many ways because
New York sets high standards and gives
us guidelines there are the new york
state guidelines and templates for and
what we're talking about here LD tease
laboratory-developed tests and you know
so there are guidelines if you want it
to look at those I'm well aware right
now that CLS I see AP other
organizations are redefining or trying
to give some guidance for lvt approval
but that is definitely what you're
talking about here
and they can be you know complex studies
but they're they're easily done I mean
you know with with resources and time
another question we have is so the
molecular testing is non pcr-based
molecular testing except acceptable and
then thank you for thanking us for the
talk so again for the molecular testing
is non pcr-based molecular testing
acceptable I guess the definition is
what they're referring to for non pcr
here Hank yeah so so here I think this
is generally that it's a very broad
questions I think the way we will talk
about it like let's say no TC are facing
Monica testings we see that could be a
director probe hybridization tests it
could be like other target amplification
because PCR is just the one type or four
you can occur acid amplification test so
we do have other like a gnome pcr basic
medical tests such as we are we talking
like the transcription mediated se the
tma and we also some other like signal
amplification essays so if you have a
lump over other options for no pcr basis
what if you are tested and like in the
firm near future we expect that lets say
the whole genome sequence that also
could be used for the medical diagnosis
like in many clinical conditions
including the bacterial vaginosis and
the paga nicest so so so in that case i
think in general we want to say get the
director aye sir to that question will
be is known pcr basin monica tests
acceptable as i will say yes however
will be depending in the jacket in my
car which it doesn't matter you're going
to choose the validation like the
perturbation approach may be a bit
different particularly if you are
interest to use the hotel
basic this is so right now we do have
some guideline community there's no
standard and consensus how you should
validate like those known pcr basis
monica test of course community for
giving is pcr basis what if your test so
70 i think that we have that the money
number two you have much more experience
then this long pcr basis what it get
test yeah i think that i'm just looking
if we have other questions certainly
what you have to do at least by New York
standards but you have to have a
comparator method that you have to do so
if you say non pcr-based molecular
testing there's got to be something
that's acceptable as a comparator method
now one of the discussions that we have
is you know the whole concept of health
care or health reform or affordable care
etc and you know that these assays bring
up the classic issues of we can do
analytics sensitivity and specificity we
can do some clinical sensitivity and
specificity I think the real question is
clinical utility and i think that the
payers will be looking for that and
right now we're talking you know we're
doing some speculation and obviously you
would need more studies but clearly
given the nature of these conditions etc
there are conditions or there are
situations where you can clearly say
that they have utility and these these
can be complex presentations with a lot
of consequences for women and certainly
in different risk groups that can be
very important to get the diagnosis
right or to be able to track the women
but i think that what is going to be
required is doing some clinical utility
studies and and so that's where we are I
you know in a simple case when somebody
presents the first time was Canada
uncomplicated and they get treated I
don't know whether you would do a
molecular test of frogs if it's an
uncomplicated patient but certainly if
you've got a complicated or a high-risk
patient and if you've got recurrent of
persistent or recalcitrant infections
then
you certainly I think can make a case
for these tests the question is going to
be is making them available validating
them and then also you know insurance
issues etc and a provider and patient
acceptance the final comment that I'd
like to make is that we you know people
are doing these on swabs right now there
are a few laboratories that are doing
them from vials and the next stage is
whether you're going to make these
samples acceptable from pap smear vials
and then you're really going to have
multiplexing because you'll have HPV and
you'll have chlamydia and gonorrhea and
you may have all these other pathogens I
don't know Hank what you think of that
but yeah wish that was that if also for
the body get tested technologies even
though i think most of all let's say
real-time pcr instrument that are able
to detect it least something like six
different colors definitely is including
let's say why you tellin control and
then typically we shall be able to even
use a TCR we can easy eat a plate needs
the for the five different target okay
i'm sorry we have one more question and
I don't know that if I have let me see
if we accept that bacterial vaginosis is
the most common cause of vaginal
discharge and if we accept that this
excuse me I'm trying to get the whole of
part I'm trying to see the whole of I'm
sorry I'm trying to get the whole
question here I Hank I don't know can
you see the whole question looks like we
have some it you have some issue with
seeing the whole question um so so how
did you get still tip and I a Christmas
year the whole question so I have to ask
if our technical support can help us see
this entire question because we
certainly would like to see it it could
be here okay I'm sorry if we accept that
bacterial vaginosis is the most common
cause of vaginal discharge and if we
accept that this vaginosis is associated
with important public health
complications such as preterm birth and
acquisition or transmission of HIV and
sexually transmitted infections would
you please explain to me what what
clearly you mean by terms of clinical
utility and clinical sensitivity in many
different cases with many different
nations with different races and with
different financial and economic
conditions well that's you're asking the
appropriate questions and you know one
of the things that the molecular methods
have shown us is that remember we have
different spectrum or presentation of BB
of what constitutes PV in different
ethnic groups and in different
geographic areas uh so you're clearly
right there and you know you're clearly
right asking the questions as to what
would be the utility I think that you
know that the different environments
need to ask those cost-effectiveness
questions to themselves but I do think
that when you have cases of when these
can be very complicated and persistent
and recurrent infections that could have
ongoing consequence for somebody or
involved future pregnancies you could
make a cost effective or you could make
cases over the cost effectiveness and
then all obviously what you would hope
is that the technology would advance
where it becomes more available and
maybe perhaps more in a
compartmentalized or you know point of
care type of technology a lot hanka so I
think this is Radio X in the questions
at India so I think of now I then I
something good
make a Libyan more complicated is like
the bv their bacterial vaginosis we know
like in the past and now now they will
know more is clearly it's prolly
microvia is not in the podium microb in
many case is just like the emergency
they'll say that the normal vaginal
microbiota so would go like in the past
the way gain more knowledge about those
people associate bacteria there are some
published their studies indicate like
some of those multiplex pcr it could be
very sensitive specific and also they
may have a very high positive and let
you predict your values however because
i think or so some of other study basil
in the microbiota from different
population has clearly indicate so there
is no such like one standard like a
normal flora and actually different
patient population you know we call the
normal flora actually could be different
the microbiota may be different so in
that case actually I think we may have a
way to go to to get to accept your
assess like the the microbiota in a
large amount of our patient populations
and until affiliate the pcr and other
including the whole genome sequence your
performance for different the patient
populations I hope we answered or that
because that's an extremely important
question and I think it's one of the
benefits that we're seeing from this
technology is that what constitutes bv
typically in one part of the world may
not not be what constitutes it in
another part of the world or in
different ethnic groups the other
interesting question here is the fact
that you have so many people who are
asymptomatic
or carry their BB without apparent
clinical symptoms and what consequence
does that have on pregnancies or STDs or
whatever and then you have women who
seem to go in and out of what you might
call a vivir pattern with or without
clinical significance so you know one of
the questions we hopefully will learn or
be able to answer is what is the
significance of these patterns do they
mean the same thing for all patients
well I I see that we're after hour hour
and we're certainly happy I mean this is
a then you know a privilege for us to be
able to present this topic and hopefully
more people will listen we would love to
hear your experience and I don't know
whether bio conference live has an
option to continue to allow us to see
input our questions and dear input or
questions from people I'm going to ask
for support if we will stay on or
whether we will sign off now so I think
that you 4eva obviously I'm sorry
question I think we have not a posterior
or we don't have a chance to answer it
so sudden will be happy to continue I
think so you could send them to your
email to us or want you to yeah yep we
would love to get people's input or
their perspective or their opinions
about this and you know carry on a
discussion with people as I said we're
actively involved here at MSR clinical
labs in development and exploration of
these tests and certainly you know we do
find in clinical situations of that
there is a usefulness for them and we do
find that they are being used commonly
in certain populations all right so I
think I know okay
I think that unless there are no more
any more questions or any more comments
that anybody has we had one more how
significant is the disturbance in the
vaginal ecosystem are the concerns of
your profession um you know i guess i
would say that the perspective we get it
from dealing with clinicians and I'll
let dr. Wang Wei and also is that you
have patients who are supposedly easy
uncomplicated but then you have patients
who aren't and who have many risk
factors and who are difficult to manage
and so when you're asking how
significant is the disturbance I think
for us this is a clinical question that
people do with clinical correlation I
think kunia i think though is the
available for next generation sequence i
think the scientific community we were
walking fitness at or the dead direction
I really don't think we have we have a
way of our like definitive I stood at
the but clearly I think yeah so we are
more I think the the research is a more
focus on the microbial communities so I
think you add the factional ecosystem so
hopefully after a couple years so we
shall have to have a bit like answers or
not i doing that yeah i think that that
question is one that is maybe to be
determined and is continually being
worked out but there's certainly a lot
of interesting information out there
that shows us the richness and the
variation in this topic again you've got
uncomplicated straightforward patients
may be first time then you've got a
number who aren't and certainly the
question about different geographies and
different resource based systems is a is
a very significant one okay I don't see
that we have any other questions and I
think we will sign off now but we thank
everybody for attending and we hope to
hear from people okay all right so
thanks